foreign
welcome back to a very special episode
of the careful boys today we have with
us Mr Jesus
horn and I didn't get it we gotta get
one can we get one installed in post how
about this one
I love it and I like it can you hear
your culture yeah I hear what culture
it's like regular talk like it of course
dude like who are some of your I like
that well yeah I like the old school
like Daddy Yankee I like Daddy Yankee I
like Don Omar I like
what I mean those type of you know they
like Celia Cruz
why you don't the fact that he did who
they was I'm like dude that's [__]
sick
what do we think for Guantanamera
deep cut you guys I like it who's your
guys at Celia Cruz in the Asian
Community Prime Vicente Fernandez
honestly I know you wanna yo I I
actually downloaded her album oh you
know what it is it's [__] Teresa Tang
dude you know Teresa Tay you know who
Teresa Tang is look at that probably get
[__] copyrighted
this is the [__] my mom grew up [__]
bumping you ready yeah dude she got a
sick photo too [__] ready for this
[__] let me see some [__] ass and
titties
some new grounds music
let's see this one is called You're
hyping us up dude it's gonna come
through
no no that's not good what the [__] is
this what the [__]
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right
I'm on yourself [__] jam out to [__]
like this oh this is like every Asian
sound I know that sounds the same yeah
dude
I know the song This is a massage for
sure I don't know I'm gonna fast for it
[Music]
When the Beat Drops
you see I like it this is our Celia Cruz
I don't know the song I don't know the
singer I don't know what she's saying
but I guarantee you it's some [__] man
[__] and power to the women without him
is that her person you've been great
this whole time you know the name of the
title is called night rain flower what
does that mean I don't know dude it's
like Beauty
you're saying like I used to [__] [__]
boys and this is what happens night
flowers that what I said yeah nitrate
rain night flower dude how is that
sounding Chinese I know who the night
flower is you know what I mean night
flowers night flowers
yeah wow and it's wet yeah wet [__]
right there dude she was talking about
laugh dudes yeah oh
try to say the Chinese title what is it
say it in Chinese I can repeat it yeah
yeah that's pretty good dude
yeah you [__] it up because now I'm
gonna go to any razor restaurant you
yeah
this one's famous this one's really
famous
this is a banger from dude I like that
flute
dude they got the lizzo any any Chinese
wedding they're playing this song oh
really it's a classic yeah and all the
parents get up and start dancing this is
the song that's what you're reading
about right now look at Cha-Cha or some
[__] huh what's she singing about what's
the context of this song
um something about the spring
they love Seasons seasonal versus Man
expect the seasons they love nature bro
they know how to respect you because
people love nature she's ovulating
that's what it is
during spring she just said she said she
says you look familiar I could have
sworn I seen you somewhere before during
the Spring [__] stuff like that oh [__]
that's her yeah she's cute oh my God
right she you can get it Teresa Tang is
what you were saying right here yeah
dude she can she's cute not only because
she can get it dude you want some of
that night flower she can have it my dad
you can have it dude I'll put it dude
I'll leave it in there and I cut it off
and I know I left it in a good [__]
place she can have it
cute the visual
was insane I know
oh trick her to let me do it and then
when it's in there it's in there oh yeah
I'll see you later my guy
I left you in a good [__] place
was she like a heartthrob too like do
you think so oh wow
bro but this pose it's like it's classic
Asian pose bro I've seen so many she's
original bro
they had a hologram of her Performance
New Year's no [__] way she's like
tupacas she's old man she's gone I mean
this is the kind of [__] my mom used to
walk with her [__] portable record
player
yeah that's a that's a hologram of her
young I guess wow I mean my mom used to
listen to her so she's gotta be old let
me tell you something she got me oh
that's tight we did about a nice petite
Asian dishes
it's a brother
Teresa tangley's the first trap
those eyebrows are going up and down
that's some Rush Hour girl [__] you do a
deep dive on Teresa oh yeah you know
what I mean
hands of the pockets like I would love
to
dude I like picture this right I picture
her we're in college
I just I'm not getting it you know I'm
not getting Algebra I know there's
algebra in college I don't know I'm not
Community College Community College you
know I'm wack and math the algebra is
the hardest person
um
and she's the [__] mad tutor and she
didn't want to she was at first arguing
with I don't want to do it you know
she's good at algebra
tattoo he's a bad boy I don't want to do
it
and we fall in love dude that's this is
my fantasy when I see this picture all
of that and this is your your college
algebra tutor
that's a sweet wholesome I know and then
he chops off his dick and leaves it in
see you later
I see some random Asian [__] I don't
even know what it means
right
were there any guys any guys like this
that you listened to uh
Cantonese like pop stuff I never
listened to it but I know some of the
like Andy Lau right like he's like
he's a he was a singer actor that's the
most like famous one I feel like that
[__] let me see if I can find stuff but
these that's Chinese I don't know this
is like old school that's right you're
like this isn't even here that's like
being Russian and German so you're so
you're the same boat as I am you're like
this is new to me I only know him from
like movies no dude all Asians know all
ages the thing about Japanese music is
is that they got they got like Japanese
Jazz are you very Japanese
Andy Lau we got Japanese salsa bro
that's what we're looking at right now
[Laughter]
it's Chinese I guess this is uh this is
a song I never thought I would ever see
someone
are you familiar with Daniela I'm not
familiar only like some of his most
famous [__] hey boys bro he's sexy guy
he's a Playboy no that's not his most
popular that sounds like a Kenny G Class
[Music]
this one yeah
why does all this [__] sound like some
Kung Fu like Rush Hour [__] like Hong
Kong if you didn't tell me what this guy
looked like today's video is brought to
you by Lumi and you know what I like
about Lumi ha so Lumi is designed by OB
GYN to keep your who Hospital fresh yep
but then they realize that this material
is so safe that you can use it anywhere
so now people put it in the armpits
whatever it stank it's a whole body
under your neck under your titties I put
it in my armpit that's back down here
where my ball sack hangs yeah the the
special hairy armpit down there it makes
everything smell fresh and if you get it
check out the fresh Alpine that's the
one that's like it's not good clean yeah
it's aluminum free that's very important
because these days there's so much
research coming out with all this [__]
like oh no there's aluminum in there
deodorant what the hell you're doing
yourself that's just gonna soak up in
your skin and you're gonna hurt yourself
also uh baking soda free paraben free
okay it's got all of the good stuff so
think about it if it works on your
hoo-ha for both guys and girls
it works everywhere else yep I can put
it right here in my neck and smell
delicious so the Lumi starter pack is
super perfect for new customers it comes
with this solid Stick deodorant cream
tube deodorant two free products of your
own choice like mini body wash and
deodorant wipes and on top of that free
shipping baby so as a special offer for
listeners that's you guys new customers
get five bucks off a Lumi starter pack
with code OTR at lumide.com that equates
over 40 off your starter pack okay when
you visit lumide.com and use the code
OTR do you know this one all right here
listen how would you picture how would
you picture them it would be him singing
it around I feel like he's showing me
his his song
you you look like dude it's my mixtape I
feel like that's you you got the vibe
the little haircut my man you like
hip-hop you like Hip-Hop Hip-Hop that's
him that's Anthony you like hip-hop Hip
Hop
am I at a Chinese Cafe and then they're
playing this [__] in the background the
cooks are watching it it is Anthony
he's got girth for sure you can just
tell those eyebrows yeah she's got a
major girl he might not be packing long
[__] length but he's got some amazing
he's got beautiful head of hair he's got
like toilet paper rolls thick got at
least a 12 inch dick dude
that's a big boy right paper towel roll
yeah dude he's a strong stump
[__] oh he [__] good in the walls
you talk about Andy lau's Dick on this
show dick is going like super smooth
Teresa dang hook hooked up don't like
the same era probably Teresa was older
Randy
dude Andy loud dude what will you do
next dude finale oh my god oh the middle
one
I love the combination of short shorts
but long sleeve jean jacket cold up top
he's a seven meter away
hey that's that's the game back then you
know what I mean are so low his [__] is
just barely it's just it's just barely
hanging if it turns around you see that
like a little bit of the butt cheek at
the top right yeah just a little bit of
the cheek he's like standing with his
shorts like is that nice you don't know
what it is a little skin nut just a
little little skin right there
he's just
he's right there in the danger zone you
know what I mean loud they were fired
Andy louder buddy
yeah Chinese Classics Chinese Classics
dude come on she's like he's an actor
right he's a big guy he's like one of
like uh daggers you were saying yeah
exactly yeah Jackie Chan movies too yeah
he's the man I mean quite nice a
handsome boy he's in drunken Drunken
Master two and on the train
if you did a Jamie Foxx of China yeah
he's like like the George Clooney I was
like Clooney but musical too though I
would say in that era he's like more
like the old school like Rat Pack where
everyone did okay like you're seeing you
acted you're dancing there's like four
main pillars of like Hong Kong like uh
music and acting and he's like one of
them who's the other ones like I know uh
Aaron Kwok is one of them too and
there's two other beautiful names
beautiful Aaron quack
beautiful
Aaron clock was uh he played Monkey King
too Monkey King three what's your name
forget their names but I know the those
are the two really big ones can I get a
side of quack
[Laughter]
I would say Jose Jose Jose Jose
first name same as the last name
he didn't [__] around Jose Jose now Jose
let me tell you about this over here
right
all right dude you know how many [__]
Loops you know how many moms you could
have [__] dude because he passed you
know this guy's up in the sky is
smashing Grandma's right now
he walked into any Latino house you say
walked in take everybody's wife
everybody's Grandma dude this guy yay
Frank Sinatra yeah yeah he did New York
he had the most beautiful voice dude wow
so he's like Mexican rat pack hey pull
up a track also
[Laughter]
because this guy knows how to he's is he
very romantic he said he's like he uses
his words and just laughs molestes you
with this
words like you don't even want to hear
you don't even want to hear it but when
you [__] listen to it you just feel
like God dude what are you doing dude
dude look at this picture dude whoa he
looks like a young Salamanca
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
that's it that's it
Jose Jose does that mean Joseph that
means
hold on hold on dude this is this one
right here dude let me tell you every
party if you put this song on dude all
the grandmas right right for you
I know he's a singer too is singing
oh my God
you know what I mean like his music
video he's just in the distance
it's a [__] fog it's so dramatic bro
oh look at
this trying to leave it he's just [__]
where you going it's like I Gotta Go
zombie boss
I have to leave Jose babe
you know what I mean Jose Jose [__] was
so dramatic one more time for Jose Jose
everybody Jose
[Laughter]
now you know where Michael Jackson got
it from dude
damn he's dope man doing road trips dude
you know like a [__] late road trips
you know you're gonna get home at five
in the morning when it's three in the
morning my dad will put that song on and
as a kid I'd just be like dude I've
never [__] before but boy did he make
me feel like I did
when you hear his songs
I feel like I just smashed and I like
you know I had a wife and I just cheated
on her yeah all of that through his
music and I'm just like I feel his pain
I get it I regretted it
this guy's [__] everyone with his
eyes right here dude that look is like I
just undressed you with my eyes
who's another who's another iconic like
artists that you grew up listening to
[__] Chalino Chalino Sanchez
dude and this is gonna be a lot of drama
dude but I never really listened to
Vicente Fernandez really really I never
really like he's one of like the top
dude oh no no he's a he's a he's a beast
he's a beast
remember it's not his family's playlist
exactly okay my dad's very romantic guy
yeah
now guys more of a like [__]
Lord
[Laughter]
some days I don't want to wake up you
know and then he makes me wake up
music we play in the back I swear to God
I don't think I can make sushi we're not
listening
[Laughter]
I can't roll up Sushi today
okay I can make something happen
yeah I mean he's just like the guy who's
like singing or Anthony so my wife was
working hard he has a song about like uh
he has a song about crossing the border
oh [__] like yeah he's like crossing the
border and just pretty much saying like
[__] you like not only am I gonna like
you deported me once but don't worry
about it I'm coming back and I'm coming
back with vengeance like I'm not only am
I gonna like take over but I'm gonna
like make your people suffer for making
me suffer like this is some wild [__]
wow not like in like a violent wave but
more like I'm gonna [__] I'm Gonna
Roll so many take over so many jobs it's
not even [__] funny that's what he's
saying he's like dude I'm gonna like
conquer United States so hard you're
gonna regret like uh hurting me and [__]
so he's a pretty good dude he gets
everybody riled up while it sounds like
that
when you're listening
yeah yeah 10 seconds
[Music]
[Laughter]
don't do this to me dude
[Music]